توالت ردود الفعل الدوليه غدا سلسله
الغارات الجويه والمدفعيه التي شنتها
تركيا على مواقع الاكراد في شمال سوريا
وخصوصا ان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يلوح
بامكانيه شم هجوم بريه ايضا وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه تعارض اي عمل عسكريا
في المنطقه المتحدث باسمها قال ان واشنطن
ابلغت انقر بقلقها الشديد من تاثير مثل
هذا الهجوم على محاربه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه
بعدم هجمات او التصعيد شركاء الولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه حاربوا تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
في السنوات الماضيه
كازاخستان حيث يعقد اجتماعه ثلاثي روسي
تركي ايراني
التركيه على سوريا
تمام بوسعها لمنع اي عمليه بريه واسعه
النطاق فرنسا ايضا اعرب
ت عدده بطريقه متكافئه على الهجمات التي
تستهدفها واعتبر المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الالمانيه ان حق الدفاع عن النفس لا يشمل
الحق في الانتقام تركيا كانت قد اطلقت
عمليتها العسكريه الجويه المحدوده هذه بعد
اسبوع على تفجير اسطنبول متهمه كل من حزب
العمال الكردستاني وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه بالوقوف خلفه لكن الطرفين نفيا اي
دور لهما بالاعتداء